welcome back to CBS mornings where we're
talking about a new warning from the
White House about what they're calling a
quote emerging threat from a potentially
deadly new drug cocktail we've all heard
about the dangers of fentanyl but now
the DEA is saying that fentanyl is being
mixed with an animal tranquilizer called
xylazine or tranq it's been found in 48
of 50 states just about everywhere and
last year about a quarter of fentanyl
powder seized by DEA agents contained
xylazine that drug Eureka Duncan
recently traveled to Georgia to see the
drug mixtures toll firsthand and also
the efforts to counter it good morning
good morning affects a lot of people and
a lot of families as well xylazine has
infiltrated the illicit drug Market here
in the Northeast at an alarming rate and
our reporting found it's not just big
cities that are dealing with this
so-called zombie drug but small
communities too leaving officials to
figure out just how to fight against it
you're seeing the impact across across
all communities no matter how big every
week first responder Jesse Michael can
see how drugs are destroying lives does
this work make a difference
um I think it definitely does he's part
of the Cobb County cares team it looks
like we got five or six different
overdoses a community outreach group
based in Marietta Georgia about 35 miles
north of Atlanta it's made up of
paramedics and Recovery Specialists or
former users who are now clean while
fentanyl has been the focus for the last
several years this is fentanyl we're
drunk an animal tranquilizer called
xylazine is showing up in street drugs
xylazine and Fentanyl combined have been
described as the deadliest drug in the
United States Missy Owen runs the Zone a
recovery support organization in
Marietta parents need to pay attention
because our 10 to 19 year olds had an
800 percent increase this past year in
fentanyl overdose in the state of
Georgia in the state of Georgia The Drug
Enforcement Administration or the DEA
has seized fentanyl mixed with with
xylazine and all but two states with the
South reporting the greatest increase of
Overdose deaths involving xylazine in
Georgia those deaths spiked eleven
hundred twenty percent over the past
three years from 15 deaths in 2020 to
183 last year xylazine's cheap
a kilo in Puerto Rico was three hundred
dollars Dan Salter worked for the DEA
for over 30 years he's now a liaison
between the federal government and local
communities like Marietta this isn't
everybody's doorstep this is not just in
Philadelphia an issue there in in South
Atlanta this is in every community in
this country what can you tell people
about the effects of xylazine so so
xylazine is a relatively new phenomenon
in the United States it's used for large
animals is not for human consumption
most the time when you cut fentanyl
Asylum you're going to have an overdose
death I later found out that they called
it trying 37-year-old Chandler who's now
in recovery believes someone gave him a
mix of Fentanyl and xylazine it's a
completely incapacitates you it put me
down for several well say about two
hours it was a terrible experience for
me I didn't I didn't enjoy it I didn't
like it how are you doing today my life
is uh my wife's beautiful today I have a
piece today that I've never known and
never experience my entire life you know
stories like Chandler's keep Missy Owen
motivated at the recovery support center
she and her husband run are pictures of
dozens of people they've lost to drug
overdoses and it was their own personal
story that brought them here their son
Davis died at 20 to a heroin overdose in
2014. it's so hard and it never gets
easier God gives me a lot of strength
because to do what we do here is
very hard it's the hardest thing I've
ever done in my life do you ever wonder
what your son would say about the work
that you and your husband are doing
it's like Mom and Dad y'all keep on
going these people need you I know that
if Davis ever gets to peek down from
heaven ever it gets to peek down he's
going to be saying y'all come here
that's my mom and dad
and I don't want him ever to see us not
working hard to make a difference for
people that could have made a difference
for him
officials tell us besides fentanyl
shrank has also been found in cocaine
meth and even marijuana in addition to
being cheap xylazine might provide a
longer high for users but it has one
very horrible side effect it appears to
cause necrosis and rots the skin from
the inside out with many users
experiencing open wounds and what's also
really unfortunate about this is right
there you would think but Narcan doesn't
work you know it doesn't necessarily
reverse the effects obviously it's mixed
with fentanyl too yeah but that's also
another part of you know the education
that they're trying to get out so people
know because a lot of times too they're
taking something that they're used to
taking to get them high right not
understanding that the xylazine is in
there and it could kill you wow I'm
still thinking about Missy Owen I always
Marvel at parents who have suffered the
greatest loss yeah all of us sitting
here are children I can't think of
anything that would be more devastating
to lose your child under any
circumstances but to take that pain and
then turn it into something to help
others and her husband are doing
incredible work there I see that yeah
there's a beauty in that though I hope I
hope anyone watching can take this as a
warning though possible death rotting
from the inside it's a serious well said
tarika thank you